bon ça y est on y est bientôt va
peut-être exister la première ria de
Mentalist au revoir akinator et bonjour
olicanator on l'appelait comme ça avec
des bras mécanique qui bouge dans tous
les sens un serveur électronique qui
calcule la toute vitesse ça c'est l'IA
tel qu'elle existe dans ma tête mais on
en est pas là l'intelligence
artificielle est la robotique ça fait la
une en ce moment de tous les sites
tchatche j'ai pété par exemple vous
connaissez pas ça c'est étonnant en tout
cas il y a elle elle vous connaît alors
est-ce que les IAH vont nous remplacer
ce qu'il y a des métiers qui vont
disparaître et comment on pourra faire
la différence entre le travail de l'IA
et celui d'un être humain j'ai envie
qu'on parle de tout ça dans dans cette
vidéo mais pour commencer dites-moi en
commentaire laquelle de ces deux photos
est générée par Unia vous faites par un
photographe je donne la réponse juste
après Loïc générique robotique
[Musique]
en parlant de l'IA laissez-moi vous
informer que cette vidéo et sponsorisée
par Odou j'ai pas abîmé ma montre non
sinon je peux l'enlever aussi alors au
dos c'est pas il y a on va y revenir
c'est un logiciel tout en un qui offre
un éventail d'application pour les
entrepreneurs et pmme gestion de la
relation client vente marketing gestion
RH comptabilité inventaire point de
vente bref eau douce et une solution
modulable qui permet une vraie faciliter
de gestion et une réduction des prises
de tête en fonction de vos besoins à
vous Audoux par exemple propose aussi
une application d'édition de site web
afin de permettre à tout le monde de
créer un site web moderne juste en
quelques clics le tout gratuitement
parce que la première application de
Houdou elle est offert ta vie la même un
nom de domaine personnalisé qui a offert
pendant un an alors en quatre étapes un
configurateur est là pour vous
accompagner dans la construction de
votre site web en fonction de vos
réponses il y a un site internet qui va
être généré automatiquement avec les
images qui conviennent à votre domaine
d'activité et comment ils font pour être
si fort c'est en prenant un coup
d'avance sur la technologie en utilisant
des formes diaperformantes qui accélère
la création de site web et pour info
odoo est lié à c'est une bibliothèque
d'images libres de droit plus besoin de
vous casser la tête pour trouver des
images parfaites c'est cool alors si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur la
création de site web avec odoo mais
aussi sur les autres services qui
proposent je vous ai mis un lien dans la
description merci au doute la star du
moment c'est donc j'ai pété on se fait
un récap chat GPT c'est un programme
développé par openahi un chatbot qui
peut comprendre et répondre à des
questions dans une conversation
plausible c'est clair ce que je viens de
dire je trouve un langage très proche
d'une autre et surtout il peut rédiger
un document apporter des informations de
façon plutôt précise même si c'est passé
sur ces qui se plante parfois au mois de
janvier la société open a fait un test
avec chantier de version chat GPT 3.5
lui on fait passer l'examen d'entrée de
la fac de droit et il a réussi avec une
moyenne peu mieux faire chuchote en
classe mais deux mois plus tard j'ai
bien deux mois et non pas 4 chats GPT
fort la dernière version a réussi
l'examen d'entrée au barreau pour être
avocat et a fait mieux que 90% des
candidats il a également réussi à faire
mieux que 99% des participants aux
Olympiades de la biologie et s'est
retrouvé parmi les meilleurs élèves aux
examens de sommelier oui chaque GPT aime
bien s'enfiler un petit ballon de temps
en temps ça va vite très vite il peut
aussi écrire des pièces de théâtre avec
des consignes précises du genre
écris-moi une pièce de théâtre qui parle
d'écologie qui serait destinée à des
enfants de 10 ans il est capable de
faire de l'humour de l'humour simple
mais aussi de l'humour sarcastique il
peut écrire des poèmes du rap des rimes
des alexandrins il peut comprendre des
images crée un site Internet à partir
d'une petite idée que tu as griffonné
sur un bout de papier c'est une taille
sauf au passé vos fringues ça y c'est
pas encore fermé ça va venir alors
évidemment tout le monde s'excite et
essayer d'être sur le coup il y a
Microsoft Google Apple li charbon pour
proposer toujours plus rapide plus fort
plus efficace terminé à l'époque où on
parlait que des NFC des métaphes là on
en parle plus du tout on parle que des
intelligences artificielles mais parce
que là c'est concret on sait à quoi ça
peut nous servir dans notre quotidien
perso professionnel alors que avant les
trucs à part verser des Bitcoin on sait
pas trop ce que c'était on voit comment
ça peut nous être utile il y a c'est
maintenant et c'est fou comme on l'a pas
vu arriver nous et les leaders du gafam
ils ont un petit peu le seum maintenant
ça va tellement vite qu'à la fin de la
vidéo les choses auront encore
mi-journée par exemple c'est capable de
générer des photos qui n'existent pas
moi la base je voulais vous parler des
doigts en trop qui sont générés sur les
mains des personnes qui a sur ses photos
c'était un petit peu flippant sauf que
le 16 mars ils ont déjà fait une mise à
jour apparemment maintenant c'est bon
mi-journée fait maintenant des mains qui
sont super réalistes avec le bon nombre
de doigts en plus ça va très très vite
impossible d'être vraiment à jour sur
les IA en ce moment et ça va très loin
la plateforme snapchat a par exemple
décidé de créer my et high une sorte
d'amis virtuelle à disposition créé à
partir de la dernière version de chat
GPT et c'est là que ça commence à
devenir flippant vous allez voir my et
high c'est un compagnon qui discute avec
vous comme si vous étiez son ami il peut
vous donner des idées de cadeaux
d'anniversaire papoter vous organisez
des excursions il apprend à connaître
vos goûts il réagit là on est au
balbutiements du compagnon de vie mais
moi ça me rappelle un peu Black Mirror
mais voilà ce qui peut nous attendre
demain pour ceux qui ont vu le superbe
film vous allez très vite voir où je
veux en venir notre prise japonaise game
box a créé un hologramme animé à
destination des personnes qui souffrent
de solitude c'est c'est ouf là vous êtes
en train de voir des images c'est
hologramme dont la bataille est une
femme de 20 ans elle s'appelle Azuma
Hikari aime les dessins animés manger
des donuts elle déteste les insectes à
la même personnalité à la dégoût il y a
des trucs elle est d'accord il y a des
trucs qu'elle aime pas elle va plus loin
elle est capable de contrôler tous les
appareils connectés de votre maison de
reconnaître votre voix votre visage elle
peut vous rappeler des rendez-vous vous
réveillez le matin et surtout c'est ça
qui est terrible elle peut vous envoyer
des petits SMS dans la journée pour dire
quand est-ce que tu rentres du travail
j'ai hâte de te voir on Somfy film quand
tu rentres j'ai repéré ça c'est cool
elle crée un lien social un lien
d'attache qu'on appelle ça et à témoigne
de l'affection et des attentes qui sont
propres à l'humain mais je vous rappelle
c'est juste un hologramme pour l'instant
le produit est pas encore sorti sur le
marché mais il est dispo en préco pour
342 dollars l'entreprise prévoit déjà
d'autres avatars disponibles en
plusieurs langues et j'imagine plusieurs
personnalités en fonction de ce que vous
voulez je vous mets le lien dans la
description si vous voulez voir la vidéo
complète salut sinon et c'est bizarre
parce que moi à la fois ça me terrifie
mais à la fois j'ai envie de faire
l'expérience de ça j'aimerais bien
essayer je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous vous seriez à
l'aise utilisé un ami virtuel là on
parle d'y avec lesquels on a des
interactions il y a aussi beaucoup
d'il y a qui sont en train de naître un
peu comme mi-journée je vous parlais
tout à l'heure qui ont juste un but qui
sont des outils là par exemple le son de
cette vidéo c'est pas ma voix c'est pas
mon son c'est Unia qui améliore tout ça
regardez je vous fais écouter sans le
travail de Lia sur mon son et sur mon
micro
voilà ben ça donne ça c'est ta vie c'est
pas mal à la base mais ça n'a rien à
voir avec quand on met en place le
travail de Lia qui rectifie ma voix et
le son ça donne ça et là c'est beaucoup
plus agréable on en parle un peu moins
en ce moment mais la robotique aussi à
l'avance beaucoup beaucoup trop vite des
robots on en a déjà plein autour de nous
il y en a qui passent l'aspirateur mais
on est loin du vrai robot comme on
s'imagine la série minds à cartonné
quand elle est sortie parce que elle
répond à ce fantasme de l'homme qui
serait d'avoir des esclaves robotiques
modernes qui pourraient faire le ménage
les courses cuisinées nous aider dans
toutes les tâches du quotidien qui nous
saoule évidemment le cul troublant dans
cette série c'est le fait qu'il
ressemble très portrait à de véritables
êtres humains et qui sont aussi
programmés pour simuler des émotions
propres à l'homme et on n'est pas si
loin avec Ameca alors à mes cas c'est un
robot il m'impressionne autant qu'il me
fait peur parce qu'il y a des
expressions faciales et des mouvements
extrêmement réalistes il a une
intelligence artificielle des mouvements
naturels c'est le robot humanoïde le
plus réaliste du monde et ce qui
m'impressionne vraiment c'est le langage
non verbal qui dégage le micro qui sont
possibles avec ces 17 moteurs
individuels qui sont placés dans sa tête
là regardez ici il y a un ingénieur qui
approche sa main près de son visage et
son mouvement de recul avec les
expressions de la surprise c'est
bluffant un peu gênant et bluffant ou
encore cet extrait l'ingénieur lui
demande de faire une démonstration de sa
routine sportive regardez la fluidité de
ces gestes et quand elle ferme les yeux
on a toutes les micros expressions de
l'apaisement de la détente la seule
chose qui lui manque à jour c'est la
mobilité dans ses jambes à mécan ne sait
pas se déplacer et son créateur Morgan
RAW affirme qu'il faudra 10 ans pour
pouvoir la faire marcher mais lors d'une
séance de questions-réponses ou c'est
Ameca qui répondait à mes cas a annoncé
que les ingénieurs planchaient sur ses
jambes et qu'elle serait opérationnelle
au cours de l'année prochaine alors on
peut faire plein de choses avec les IA
voici en vrac des domaines où elles vont
vite nous être indispensables par
exemple le robot chirurgien star c'est
son nom des chercheurs de l'Université
John Hopkins aux États-Unis ont créé le
tout premier robot chirurgical qui
complètement autonome il peut opérer
sans l'assistance d'un être humain il
serait plus fiable que le meilleur des
chirurgiens humains pour certaines
opérations depuis quelques semaines on
s'est désormais qu'un robot peut opérer
de manière autonome un cochon pas encore
un être humain il a réalisé une ananas
tomose intestinale c'est une opération
très complexe ça demande des années
d'apprentissage parce qu'il s'agit de
raccrocher deux extrémités intestinales
comme c'est des tissus qui sont mous et
qui grosso modo change de place cette
forme c'est ne pas ration qui est
dangereuse pour la survie du patient
donc pour le moment il y a pas eu
d'opération sur des êtres humains mais
autant vous dire que ça ne serait tardé
dans le domaine juridique qui a
contracte intelligence qui a été
développé par JP Morgan c'est un
logiciel qui permet d'analyser les
accords de prêt commerciaux et qui
remplacent en moyenne 360
000 heures de travail par an ça calme
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup autrement
dit il fait le travail d'un assistant
juridique dans la fonction et de passer
des heures et des heures à faire des
recherches sur les clos spécifiques les
montants adaptés l'analyse de conformité
des contrats et bien tout ça contractez
intelligence le fait ça sent pas bon
pour certains métiers ce qui a une de ce
passé c'est que les spécialistes doivent
apprendre et accepter d'apprendre de
servir des IA pour être aussi productif
et compétitif que les sociétés qui
fourniront des résultats qui seront
fulls créés par c'est mon hypothèse
c'est ma théorie ça n'engage que moi
mais ça fait un peu flipper je sais pas
ce que ça va donner mais je crois qu'on
va devoir composer avec on n'a pas le
choix tout en faisant attention pour le
moment quand je vois le travail qui est
passé ce chat GPT je trouve que ça se
sent c'est pas original c'est pas bien
écrit c'est même assez lourd mais si les
yeux créatifs sont leurs débuts alors on
risque de vite halluciner dans les mois
dans les semaines dans les jours qui
viennent le métier d'assistant juridique
il est en danger ok mais il y a aussi
celui de comptable des études annoncent
même que ce métier à 64 % de chances
d'être remplacé par des IA il y a plein
de logiciels il y a plein d'applications
qui permettent aujourd'hui de récupérer
de façon automatisée les comptes
bancaires de télécharger les notes de
frais d'assurer le suivi de la
trésorerie d'un chiffre d'affaires tout
ça bon cette profession elle est donc
amenée à évoluer en étant plus des
conseillers que des comptables à
proprement parler tel qu'ils le font
aujourd'hui autre domaine à Paris de
depuis 2011 à l'hôpital Saint-Louis ils
utilisent une plateforme de diagnostic
biologique automatisé qui analyse les
prélèvements elle traite pas moins de
1400 dossiers par jour elle fournit un
million de résultats par mois à tous les
services de l'hôpital il y a des
programmes en cours de test qui
permettrait de pouvoir le mouvement
détecter des cancers pour poser des
traitements plus adaptés plus rapidement
donc évidemment il y a du bon dans ce
qui peut ressortir de l'IA tout dépendra
de notre utilisation même s'il y a des
métiers qui commencent à flipper
sérieusement ceux des rédacteurs des
correcteurs des traducteurs peut-être
même des enseignants même les codeurs se
posent des questions dans les IA elles
peuvent générer des codes propres de
qualité pour créer le programme qu'on
lui a juste à peine expliquer la seule
solution aujourd'hui pour les métiers de
l'écrit c'est de montrer leur valeur par
le style l'originalité et l'âme qui met
dans leur travail ou de se reconvertir à
chaque révolution technologique ou
industrielle on a toujours vu apparaître
des nouveaux métiers donc bientôt vous
allez peut-être devenir spécialiste en
éthique de l'IA ça va être des
spécialistes en éthiques de l'IA qui
vont travailler sur les questions liées
à l'utilisation responsable de l'IA la
transparence la sécurité la
confidentialité l'équité ou alors vous
serez coach en IA les coachchands vont
aider des entreprises intégrées liées à
dans leurs opérations et former les
employés à l'utilisation de bien ou
alors vous êtes peut-être déjà ingénieur
prompte parler à une Niasse à ce travail
il y a juste à regarder sur Tik Tok la
masse de vidéo ou sur Youtube aussi de
personnes qui explique plusieurs astuces
pour bien parler à chat GPT pour avoir
la meilleure réponse possible et ça ça
va être un vrai taf d'être capable de
comprendre les IA de savoir poser les
bonnes questions c'est un art et ça
permet d'avoir des bonnes réponses et
c'est un métier qui est en plein boom la
preuve j'ai dit boom des dresseurs dia
on les abeille comme ça c'est un peu des
psy pour les machines il faut qu'ils les
comprennent il y a plein de choses
encore donc j'aimerais vous parler sur
sur le domaine de l'IA mais plus en
détail faire des focus un peu plus
précis je sais pas si ça vous tente
qu'on en parle par exemple j'ai publié
une vidéo Tik Tok avec mes promptes pour
mémoriser une information complexe hyper
facilement avec la méthode de findman la
méthode de findman vous avez parlé sur
une vidéo YouTube l'année dernière la
méthode la plus efficace pour mémoriser
quelque chose bon j'ai trouvé comment
amener le chat gepetty à s'en servir et
du coup ça m'a pris 5 minutes au lieu de
5 heures à 5 jours pour apprendre ce que
je vais demander hyper intéressant alors
je vous pose la question est-ce qu'on se
fait une série là-dessus le mentalisme
2.0 en fait vous aviez trouvé quelle
photo était réelle au début de la vidéo
c'est celle-ci qui est réel celle-ci
elle a été générée parmi une journée je
les ai pas mais moi je vois pas
d'énormes différences et vous est-ce que
vous aviez trouvé est-ce pas vraiment
vous êtes des détecteurs dia ou est-ce
que là en ce moment vous commencez à
vous poser le même question que moi
répondez-moi à tout ça dans les
commentaires
écrivez à votre mère régulièrement
rendre des nouvelles c'est important
attention quand même à ce qu'on va voir
circuler dans les prochaines années les
fake news avec les images créer avec les
synthèses de voix qui ressemble à une
vraie voix le lipsing le Deep face le
Deep fake mais de la fesse comme dirait
Loïc c'est bizarre fesse de la fesse
aucun rapport non mais vous voyez ce que
je veux dire déjà aujourd'hui les fake
news ça fait des ravages mais à terme on
va pu être capable de différencier le
vrai du faux il y a 26 experts dans le
domaine qu'on fait un rapport qui est
baptisé l'utilisation malveillante de
l'intelligence artificielle anticipation
prévention et modération c'est un
rapport qui fait 100 pages et où ils ont
listé un peu les usages dangereux
potentiels sur lesquels il faudra un
petit peu se méfier merci encore à Odou
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à les découvrir leurs services via
le lien dans la description abonnez-vous
abonnez-vous à cette chaîne Youtube tu
vas ça y est corriger à très bientôt
Ciao